hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game that they just finished in
the shock bundesliga it's a hans mokane
versus fabiano corona a lot of you guys
already requested it as it features a
very very rare position that you guys
will enjoy if you if you don't know what
i'm talking about uh before we check out
the actual game a few words about the
upcoming magnus carlsen versus yanni
palmistry world church championship
match we still don't know if magnus will
play uh like i said uh he did meet with
fide president arkady vorkovich during
his visit in madrid in the video
candidates tournament they discussed
that we don't know exactly what was
discussed but uh as uh you know this has
been going around for for quite a few
days now they did ask magnus uh politely
to decide uh until the 20th of this
month the 20th of june of july whether
he will play or not so that's like uh he
has like 12 days and now i don't know if
this is like a serious deadline because
it would be very weird if it was uh they
still don't have the venue the sponsors
they really have nothing so it's uh it
would be very hard for magnus to decide
um you know based on that uh and the
magnus as i'm told it did suggest some
changes to the uh to the format uh that
that will be used for the world
championship match so now we'll we'll
see what they come up with i will keep
you guys informed now getting back to
this incredible game uh neiman has the
white pieces and he opens with e4 and
it's a very very interesting uh
situation for niman because he's been
playing some incredible classical chess
lately and fabi is basically just out of
defeated candidates tournament so you
know that he is uh well as aside from
playing the world chair championship
match uh he is as prepared as a chess
player can get and he is also fabi you
know he's a former 2800 player uh who's
just incredibly strong so what do you
play against him uh definitely not the
not the uh the real lopez as we've seen
so much of that in the candidates um
obviously nieman will avoid that so e5
knight to f3 knight to c6 and now bishop
to c4 and even goes for the italian game
and fabio replies with bishop to c5 he
goes for the joko piano and now c3 the
main line of the joko piano not going
for the strongest move with pawn to b4
but okay we have knight to f6 uh d3 d6
and uh neiman castles we have pawn to a6
and rook to e1 somewhat rare but on this
level probably not to either of them we
have bishop to a7 and pawn to a for now
grabbing more space on the queen side
castles by fabi and h3 and here we have
some trades that are also well known
bishop to e6 offers a trade uh niemann
trades captures captures and uh bishop
to e3 so the bishops leave the board
with bishop characters in the rook
characters on e3
uh and here uh again the position is a
known one uh for example maxima
shilograph had it against dmitry
akovenko twice so once uh yeah maxine
won once uh one once the game ended in a
draw of a5 was played in that game uh
also in anishigiri versus uh
kovalev uh also the game ended in a draw
but here fabi uh has a different idea he
plays a move that has never been played
before and that is pawn to d5 now of
course you know that this move is coming
usually when black plays it if he can
play it black will be perfectly fine uh
so what is the idea behind the early d5
well point is if you capture on d5 uh
fabi does not capture with the pawn favi
plays knight captures on the e5 attacks
the rook and once you move the rook then
he plays knight to f4 and already you
can see that this is not the position
you had in mind i mean you have the
white pieces you're not you do not want
a black knight on f4 uh the rook with
easy access to the attack the queen and
knight already attacking the d3 pawn so
it might be a bit uh uncomfortable uh so
instead after this d5 move we have
knight b to d2 just adding another
defender to the pawn here and now pawn
to d4 this is fabi's original plan rook
back to e1 of course we're not going to
allow fabi to undouble his pawns for
free so rook to e1 and d captures on c3
b captures and queen captures and v3
fabi wins the pawn but his pawn
structure is a little
messed up and perhaps weak it's a double
e pawn also the b7 pawn is weak so now
just queen to b3 attacking both b7 and
the e6 pawn luckily uh fabi can defend
both of them he plays queen to d6 and of
course the b7 pawn cannot be captured uh
for the moment if you play queen
captures there will be a trap to the
queen all right it doesn't drop the
queen you can play knight c4 but still
we we're gonna win the night tonight
capture spawn captures and the fobby's
now up a knight so instead we have rook
8 to d1 now threatening all sorts of
nasty discoveries and rook 8 to b8 just
defending the b7 pawn
knights the c4 attacking the queen and
going after that e5 pawn and queen c5
just keeping an eye on the pawn we have
knight back to e3 preparing to
offer a queen trade and now rook after
e8 now everything is nicely defended the
e6 pawn is defended b7 pawn is defended
and now fabi will uh slowly but surely
try to take advantage of his extra pawn
perhaps so here queen c4 offering a
queen trade and fabi goes back he says
nope i prefer your knight on e3 not on
c4 so queen e7 uh knights the c2 now
will try to offer the knight trade and
the b4 square uh rook beat the d8
offering sorry rugby 38 offering a rook
trade and neiman trades once with rook
captures rook captures and knight to b4
of course fabio also doesn't want to fix
his pawn structure for free so knight a5
chases away the queen queen a2 and now
pawn to c5 so now anyone wants to keep
the queen on this diagonal as it makes
sense the
e6 pawn is weak maybe later on you can
even attack it with knight to g5 but
first he has to decide what to do with
the knight so knight back to c2 and now
knight to c6 so it's not easy for fabi
to get a
nice square for his knights and also
it's not easy for neiman to get a nice
square for his knights the bishops are
out of the game so we just have to
control the knights knights the a3 again
going for that c4 square to go after the
e5 pawn and now knight to h5 by fabi and
this is where things get very very
interesting uh here uh neiman plays g3
now the really fun part is that if you
go for knight to c4 which is kind of the
original plan you want to go after this
e5 pawn fobby has the incredibly tricky
knight to f4 move and now you can't go
for the e5 pawn just yet because if you
do it if you capture on e5 fabby just
trades captures captures and he has this
insta win rook to d2 beautiful stuff and
this is a uh this is a
a tactic you guys want to remember now
to use in your own games point is that
queen to g5 is our move but if we just
play queen to g5 white will defend this
way we attack the queen we bring the
rook into the attack and now if the uh
rook is accepted now queen g5 uh wins
the game because we're threatening
checkmate and once uh
white stops this somehow let's play
something like f3 now queen defends the
pawn we just play knight captures an h3
check and pick up the free queen so
basically what you would have to do
after this knight to f4 move you can't
go after the pawn you would have to play
something like rook to e3 and then the
game continues fabi uh would
gain some pawns here on the on the queen
side would rather start pushing them
let's say queen a6 and even can go after
this knight so the game just continues
uh however after g3 uh this is the
moment where fabi really gets his uh
pieces to some very very cool squares we
rook to d3 attacks the knight as this is
this square has just been weakened uh as
josh wadeskin would say the square left
behind uh queen to e2 now defending the
knight uh and rook captures in c3 but
it's not really a a free pawn uh because
knight to b1 attacks the rook and you
can't go to c2 or c4 the queen covers
that so rook to b3 and now knights the
d2 so what was fabi's idea now his rook
is hanging and his knight is hanging but
fabi's idea was knight captures on g3
and now you can't really go after the
knight if you capture then rook captures
with check
you are getting destroyed here if king
h2 queen h4
and good luck defending this okay you
can play queen f1 maybe defend but then
the knight comes into the game the b5
pawn will be played and you start
pushing past pawns
this will be
very easily winning for fobby so instead
of queen g4 now putting some pressure on
the knight also the queen will guard the
pawn when uh pawn recaptures but now h5
attacks the queen queen to g6 and now we
have knight to e2 with check uh
there's no way to save the knight you
have to give it up somehow a very
interesting idea is also rook to d3 we
can show it because it's very very quick
f captures on g3 and now h4 and it's
incredibly difficult to find moves here
for white basically only defensive idea
is knight to f1 to guard the pawn here
but now c for now this point is marching
forward and the the pawns here that fabi
has on the queen side he can easily
create two past pawns uh are the actual
strength of the position the you know
the the weak king's position is just a
bonus uh but okay after queen to g6 fabi
goes for a different idea and knight to
e2 with check rook captures and now rook
captures an h3 now completely busting
open the king side he is down a piece
but he does have a lot of pawns and well
he he does have the attack so rookie
three offering a rook trait and fabi
doesn't trade instead he goes rook to h4
he still wants to keep the rook into the
in the game
also rook the g for check now would win
the queen so rook to g3 uh the other way
to the uh to defend here is king to f1
and king to f1 is slightly better than
the instant rook to g3
but you will only realize that when you
see fabi's next move so rook to g3
and now knight to d4 and now
it's very very tricky now king to f1 is
no longer possible that's why king f1
was better in that position because if
you play king f1 here now rook h1 check
you can't go to e2 and after king g2
there's even knights to e2 beautiful
stuff you can't capture the rogue
because queen to h for check will pretty
much end the game and uh you don't have
a good move here you will have to go
into this queen captures and g7 check
queen captures rook captures king
captures now king captures an h1 and now
b5 captures captures and we get this
position where black is up three pawns
uh but uh white is up a full night so it
would be tricky to win this with black
however it would be only black uh trying
uh to win this but um you know still
better than what was played in the game
in the game night the c3 was played and
this allows fabi to
well start pushing on the queen side
before uh trading off pretty much
everything else so a b5 king to f1 and
now pawn to c4 threatening b4 and you
can't really allow b4 if b4 and then the
pawns start marching forward even
further uh then you resign so a captures
eight captures and here niemann gives up
the knight it's the only move to defend
the position uh because like i said if
you play something there's really no no
other move to play uh once the pawns
start marching forward is the game over
c3 knight somewhere it doesn't really
matter captures capture c2 in that game
so after a captures on b5 knight
captures on b5 okay fabi takes back the
knight and now we have knight to f3
attacking uh fabi's rook knight captures
on c4 is the safest
uh choice but he goes after the rook
here so rook to g4 and now knights the
g5 going after that h7 square but again
uh the the safer choice was capturing
the rook maybe but it's still uh very
hard to play if rook captures h captures
knights the g5 it seems like maybe okay
you've done uh
better here but not really after queen
to d7 you will not be checkmating the
black king you're not even winning this
because after queen h7 check king of f8
queen h8 check king to e7 you even
grabbed the pawn there's king to d6 and
you've uh gotten your king to safety now
not a lot to worry about here and the
past c pawn will just win the game you
have a let's say this checked king will
go to c6 then the king can also go down
the board help out to escort the pawn
and that's it so okay after rook g4 we
have knight to g5 keeping the rooks in
the game but of course now fabi plays
rook captures on g5 he doesn't go after
the if you play rook captures on g3 then
of course it is checkmate queen h7
checking a fade and queen to aj
checkmate uh but this move uh helps uh
fabi
uh start pushing for the win he grabs
the knight uh we have queen captures
offering a queen trade and now he trades
captures captures and pawn to c3 now
just c to c1 and fabi wins however
the rook is in time rook captures on c5
c2 we have rook to c5 and now knight to
d4 defending the c2 pawn also preventing
king the e2 so pawn to uh
f4 and now pawn to e5 trying to give up
a pawn you can't capture with the rogue
because c1 queen uh you could advance
the pawn that's uh one option but then
we go uh uh with with the king so here
niemann decides to capture but this now
gives up uh uh well just a way for
fabi's g pawn so g5 uh rook to c7 and
now king to f8 by fabi we have pawn to
e6 now comes h4 and e7 with check we've
kinked the e8 and pawn to e5 now fabi
continues pushing g4 now comes e6 and
look at this of course um
the knight cannot capture because the
knight needs to guard the c2 pawn
however fabi's king does not have a
single square to go to this is just
incredible so what can he do here well
h3 uh we have kinked the f2 and now uh
there are a couple of moves you could
try here fabi obviously founded the
trickiest one he played knight to e2 and
now it is uh incredibly important uh to
study this position this is a position
you want to remember you know print
screen and save it the any way you like
you know show it to your friends at the
bar in the library uh you will make
their day definitely i guarantee it
because this is one of those positions
that uh
just make chase just the greatest game
ever ever made so feel free to pause the
video here and try to find it the only
way to save the game for niman while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on uh sporting this
brilliancy and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is uh rook the
c8 with check uh that's the that's the
good stuff but to understand why rook
the c8 check has to be played here uh
first we're gonna check out what
happened in the actual game in the game
uh of course neiman went for rook
captures on c2 because i mean who
wouldn't
and now the problem is fabi has this uh
incredible g3 check move
that's the problem and now we have king
to f3 g2 and now you don't have a move
and that's the problem so what would
happen in that position if rook the c8
check was played instead of rook to e2
well remember this position well
after this uh knight to 82 move if rook
the c8 check was played instead
king captures and e7 is the only move
now we play rook to c7 with check and
and now after king captures an e6 you've
eliminated all of the pawns and now you
just repeat what you did in the game
only without the pawns on e7 and e6 now
rook captures on c2 and now if g3 check
king f3 and g2 we play rook captures on
e2 but now it comes with check the king
is not safe here guarded by the pawns on
e7 and e6 that's the
that's the point so basically after rook
captures on c2 uh you're gonna have to
play something like knights to d4 you
attack the rook but now after let's say
rook to c8 we go knight to f5 rook to g8
and the pawns are now uh
stopped if you play g3 we happily give
up the rook here rook captures knight
captures king captures and we capture
the other pawn and it's a draw that's it
uh so that's what you had to do here uh
also uh you can't play king captures on
e2 if you play king captures i need to
just h2 there's no stopping the h pawn i
didn't even mention that but uh the
the other one was important but here
after rook captures on c2 the problem is
your own pawns are uh preventing you
from checking the black king so it seems
like such a odd thing to do you know
completely counter-intuitive you know
giving up your price the
pawns on e7 and e6 but you know it had
it had to be done so g3 with check we
have came to f3 g2 now there is no point
in capturing the knight because fabi
just brings the queen into the game so
rook the c8 would check king captures on
e7 and now rook the g8 if you're
wondering why not rook c7 check of
course black will not capture the pawn
black will go king f6 and now okay you
can play rook f7 check now you can
capture it but now you don't really have
a good move anymore you have to play
rook g7 and now you are hoping to
sacrifice your rook for the two pawns
but knight f4 saves the day this would
be the only winning move but of course
it's very easy for both fabi and nieman
to calculate this uh there's no way to
play this anymore the g2 pawn is nicely
defended and if you accept the knight
then h2 and that's it of course the
rogue captures h1 check h1 brings the
queen into the game and it's uh the
famous queen and rook end game that fabi
will win
uh so after this uh king captures on e7
we have rooked the g8 and now again
knight the f4 going into the exact same
position where you have to capture the
knight otherwise uh well h2 is coming uh
so it's it's just important to prevent
uh neiman from giving up the rook for
the two pawns so knight f4 defends the
pawn king captures h2 rook captures on
g2 and now h1 queen and we get into a
position where it's queen against rook
and of course you guys are uh extremely
good at chess you guys know how to win
this easily rook to e2 uh
putting the rook behind the pass pawn
but it doesn't really make all that much
difference queen to f1 check now the
king has to defend the rook king the e3
and now king captures and e6 so no more
pass pawn and now you have this queen
and rocket game uh it's been studied the
scene since forever even uh josero
capoblanca the former world champion
said that it's one of the hardest end
games the to win if you don't know
exactly what to do but uh luckily there
is uh
this thing called the the the philidor
position that you guys know
and then if you notice it is extremely
easy to uh to win this so basically what
you want to do is you want to push the
white king all the way to one side of
the board and then into the corner and
once you've accomplished this uh then
white will at some point have to move
the rook away from the king and at this
exact moment when white does this or you
know whoever has the rook
you will just you know give a series of
checks and win the rook so it's very
very simple actually uh here rook the c2
is played and now fabi will uh display
um
how he does this so rook to c2 uh we
have king to d5 we have to use our king
also to cut off the uh the white king we
rook back to e2 and now queen to f5 uh
we have rooked the d2 check king the e5
rook to e2 and now queen to h3 with
check so now you can see the black king
is preventing the white king from going
anywhere forward you have to go back
king f2 now king to f4 just keeping the
opposition uh we have king the e1 and
now queen the c3 with check we have king
to f1 and now a very nice queen to d4
move now just uh keeping an eye on these
squares here and asking what do you want
to do here so the point is if rook have
to check then we play king g3 and we're
already threatening checkmate so once
you give one check king to f3 now you
can no longer play king a rook to f2 and
you will have to move the rook away for
example rook to rook to e2 to prevent
rook queen to d1 checkmate but now we
play queen d3 and of course uh win the
rook on the next move and check made the
king
so after this queen to d4 move king to
g2 is played uh very very tricky idea uh
and now comes king to g4 uh rook to f2
now queen to d5 with check sorry queen
to d5 with check king to h2 and now
queen to e4 again uh just making it very
very difficult for the white king to
move uh we have rooked the g2 with check
again if king to g1 then we play king to
g3 and again it's the exact same thing
you can't deliver a check uh also queen
to e1 will be checkmate if you move the
rook somewhere weird uh so not uh not a
lot to do so here rook to g2 this comes
with check king to f3 we have king to g1
and the now queen the h4 again making it
impossible for
white king to go anywhere uh if king f1
queen h3 again we will win the rook this
way so instead we rook to g8 finally the
rook has to leave
at the safety of the white king and now
it's uh very easy to just either win the
rook or checkmate the white king here
fabi played queen to e1 with check king
to h2 now comes queen to e2 with czech
king h1 queen to e1 with check king h2
and now queen to d2 with check and it
was in this position on move 77 that han
smoke and eamon resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here so
uh you if you go for example something
like uh king to h3 then it's queen to h6
checkmate that's one way to do it as of
course the king covers all of this and
the queen now delivers check or the
other way which is a lot more fun if you
go king back to h1 now we play well we
can win this many different ways but
basically queen a2 is the way to do it
the coolest way we attack the rook uh
and once uh white gives one check now we
just play king to g3 and now there is
nothing you can do uh there's no check
the queen covers g8 we are threatening
queen to a1 that will be checkmate queen
b1 that will be checkmate once white
gives up the rook a queen the g2 will be
checkmate queen to h2 will be checkmate
there is no way to defend against all of
these threats so of course you uh
resigned this
so after queen d2 checked niman resigned
and a a wonderful wonderful victory for
fabi against the joko piano uh
with with the black pieces very very
nicely done
uh
and you know a very nice bounce back
after that terrible second half of the
candidates tournament uh so yeah a tough
break for nieman losing a game with
white but it is against fabi who just
played the candidates uh so you know
no no one would do better
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it a lot of really really
awesome positions here like this one i
really hope you guys um if anyone
actually paused the video here and found
this rook to see a check move that you
have to give up the pawns in order to
survive this uh you know you have a
bright future in front of you so really
awesome positions really awesome end
game and in the end you have to know how
to win a filterous position uh if you
don't then you're just going to have to
offer a draw and that's it
uh so yeah that's the game really hope
you guys enjoyed it i would like to wish
a very happy birthday to christine
and i would like to thank richard
sanders and matteo georgia always
cluster harbor and um common d for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions such as this one
and whatever else happens in the chess
world uh so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day and i will keep you updated on the
magnus vs nipple world chess
championship match news uh see you soon